welcome to the game is Danny's bet
there's more you know the left see low
each contestant starts off with $37,000
in debt the right answers will help them
half their debt but the wrong answers
are going to increase their debt all
right let's fight what is the total
student loan debt in the u.s. a 1.5 3
trillion or feed seven point five three
billion Brian hey what was the average
monthly payment for student loans in
2017 was it a 100 200 dollars be two
hundred to three hundred dollars or see
three hundred to four hundred homes
Shayla hey when can you apply for
scholarships
hey when you first apply to college B
between college semesters C during your
senior year of high school or deep all
of the above all of the above that is
correct
which of these is best for your college
budget a meal prepping be eating ramen C
going on dates for free food or D our
game makes you our winner unfortunately
you did lose so you are drowning in debt
thanks for playing the game of student
debt
[Music]